ما التفاصيل التي رشحت عن اجتماع المجلس
الوزاري المصغر ومجلس الحرب
ايضا نعم محمد يعني موضوعات كثيره على
الاجنده الاسرائيليه كانت لهذا المساء
وايضا فجر هذا اليوم بدايه مجلس الحرب
الاسرائيلي وكما قالت القناه الثانيه عش
الاسرائيليه بحث صفقه جديده لتبادل الاسرى
بعدما تلقى عبر الوسطاء عرضا جديدا من
حركه حماس حول هذه الصفقه وبنود هذه
الصفقه حتى الان التسريبات تشير الى ان
حماس تطلب بدايه اسبوعين من الهدنه قبل
الافراج عن اي اسير اسرائيلي ثم تبدا
بالافراج على دفعات عن اسرى اسرائيليين
مقابل هدنه مستمره قد تستمر هذه الدفعات
وهذه الهدنه الى شهرين كما جاء في
التسريبات وتشير التسريبات ايضا الى ان
هناك مطالب بان يتم الافراج عن 100 اسير
فلسطيني مقابل كل اسير اسرائيلي يتم
الافراج عنه من قطاع غزه وفي في المرحله
الاخيره يجري الافراج عن مئات الاسرى
الفلسطينيين مقابل المزيد من الاسرى
الاسرائيليين من قطاع غزه حتى الان لم
تصدر اي يعني تسريبات حول ماذا قرر مجلس
الحرب الاسرائيلي ولكن خلال الايام
القادمه سيجري رئيس جهاز المساد وكذلك
رئيس جهاز الامن العام الشباك
وا اجتماعا مع رئيس المخابرات المركزيه
الامريكيه وكذلك رئيس الوزراء وزير الخارج
القطر اجتماعا في احدى الدول الاوروبيه
التي تصفها الوسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه
بانها دوله هامه للغايه هذا الاجتماع
سيخوض في تفاصيل صفقه تبادل الاسرى وهناك
يعني وسائل الاعلام الاسرائيليه تولي هذه
الاجتماعات يعني اهميه قصوى وتتحدث عنها
باسهاب وكما يبدو ان هذا الاجتماع سيكون
له ما بعده وذلك لانه قد يسبب اختراقا
كبيرا في مجريات الحرب الاسرائيليه وكذلك
صفقه تبادل دل الاسرى هناك مصدر اسرائيلي
ايضا قال اليوم للقناه الثانيه عش ان
اسرائيل مستعده ل يعني تقديم الكثير
ولكنها غير مستعده لتبيييض سجونها بالكامل
هذا تصريح ايضا مهم ياتي قبل عقد هذه
الاجتماعات في تلك الدوله الاوروبيه طبعا
الى ذلك الى جانب ذلك محمد بحث مجلس
الوزاري المصغر للشؤون الامنيه والسياسيه
في اسرائيل ولاول مره فعليا ينجح في عقد
جلسه لبحث اليوم التالي كما يقال لقطاع
غزه ما بعد الحرب ولكن لم تتخذ حتى الان
اي قرارات تتعلق في المشهد الذي تراه
اسرائيل لقطاع غزه ما بعد الحرب وقد قرر
المجلس ان يعقد سلسله اجتماعات خلال
الايام القريبه القادمه لبحث هذا الموضوع
كما اجرى ايضا وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي اف
جلنت مع نظيره الامريكي لويد اوستين
اتصالا هاتفيا هذا المساء وبحثا من خلاله
ايضا اليوم التالي لغزه ما بعد الحرب
وكذلك ادخال المزيد من المساعدات
الانسانيه لقطاع غزه كما اكد وزير الدفاع
الامريكي كما كل مره التزام بلاده بدعم
اسرائيل